احييكم مشاهدينا مساء الخير انا ميسون
نواهد واقدم لكم اخبار الساعه نبدا
بالعناوين
قبيل الاعاده اردوغان يعد بفوز تاريخي
واكلتش دار اوبلو يتعهد بقتال حتى النهايه
اما السنان اوغان يضع شروطه
[موسيقى]
جوله الاوروبيه تملا مخازن اوكرانيا
بالصواريخ والمسيرات لكنها تتعثر فيما
يتعلق بالمقاتلات
واشنطن تتهم طهران بتقديم 400 مسيره
انتحاريه لموسكو منذ اغسطس وتقول ان
شاركتهما تتوسع
محكمه تونسيه مختصه بقضايا الارهاب تقضي
بالسجن عاما لراشد الغنوشي زعيم حركه
النهضه
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم في اخبار الساعه البدايه طبعا من
تركيا فهناك لم تعد الكلمه الفصل في مصير
الانتخابات الرئاسيه في يدي رجب طيب
اردوغان وكمال كلتش دار اوغلو وحدهما
وانما بات سنان اوغان المرشح الخاسر هو
صانع الملوك بحكم الامر الواقع فما حصل
عليه من اصوات قد يحدد الرئيس القادم
لتركيا امر يعيه اوغان جيدا ولذا بادر
بوضع شروطه
[موسيقى]
يبدو ان الانتخابات تتجه نحو اجراء جوله
ثانيه ومن سيحسمهاهم القوميون الاتراك
واتباع كمال اتاتورك ايها الاصدقاء
الاعزاء امامنا خمسه عشر يوما اضافيه صعبه
وخلال هذه الفتره وفي حال انتهت
الانتخابات بالنتائج الحاليه وذهبنا الى
جوله ثانيه فسوف نبذل قصار جهودنا لجعل
هذه العمليه الانتخابيه مفيده لامه
وبلادنا وفي هذه الاثناء لا نقول اننا سوف
ندعم طرفا دون سواه
الجوله الاولى من الانتخابات التركيه باحت
بكل اسرارها معلنه عن جوله ثانيه غير
مسبوقه في تاريخ البلاد رجب طيب اردوغان
وكمان كيليش دار اوغلو يترشحان للجوله
الثانيه
ومنافسهما ثالث
يخرج من الباب الضيق بعد حصوله على نحو 5%
فقط من الاصوات لكن المفارقه الغريبه
مشاهدينا ان هذه الخمسه بالمئه الخاسره
ستحدد مصير الرئاسه في تركيا هي هزيمه اذا
لكن قد تكون بنكهه الانتصار فلمن ستذهب يا
ترى الاصوات الحاسمه
قد يبدو غريبا ان اسم سنان اوغان اصبح
اكثر تداولا بعد انتهاء الجوله الاولى من
الانتخابات مما كان عليه الحال قبل
انطلاقها والسبب ربما هو انه بات يملك بين
يديه الورقه التي ترجح كافه طرف على حساب
اخر في الجوله الثانيه وعمليا ستكون اصوات
في الجوله الثانيه بعد اسبوعين والتي بلغ
عددها نحو بل ثلاثه ملايين صوت في الجوله
الاولى
يدرك جيدا قوه موقفه في الوقت الراهن
فسيناريو الانتخابات رفع من اسهم قاعدته
الانتخابيه بشكل كبير وجان حقق تماما ما
كان يصبو اليه مع بدايه الانتخابات فهو
كان يعلم ان حدوده في المنافسه على
الرئاسه منعدمه في ظل قوه منافسيه لذا
اقصى طموحه كانت توجه الى جوله ثانيه لان
ذلك يعني ارغام المترشحين المتبقين على
التفاوض معه والاستجابه للشروطه
فما هي يا ترى شروط اوغان اهم شرطين
لاوجاعين على حد قولهما محاربه الارهاب
واعاده اللاجئين واذا كان الشرط الاول يجد
استجابه لدى معسكر اردوغان فان الوضع
يختلف لدى معسكر كريتشدار والعكس صحيح
بالنسبه للشرط الثاني في اردوغان يتبنى
موقف العوده الطوعيه للسوريين وهو ما قد
يستغرق بضعه سنوات اما كلتش دار اوغلو فقد
ابدى اكثر من مره تاييده لترحيل اللاجئين
السوريين ولكن ما قد يعيق اي توافق بين
اوغان وكيلوا هي العلاقه مع الاحزاب
الكرديه حيث ان اوغان يرفض اي تحالف معهم
ويتهم الاجنحه العسكريه للاحزاب الكرديه
بالارهاب
ودائما لمتابعه ما يجري على الارض نذهب
الى شبكه مراسلي العربيه من اسطنبول ينضم
الى المفرد العربيه طاهر بركي من انقره
مراسلنا زيدان طاهر ابدا معك جوله الاعاده
اصبحت امرا واقعا الاجواء اليوم بعد هذه
النتيجه والذهاب الى جوله اعاده
اهلا ميسون اهلا زيدان وابي المشاهدين
الكرام الاجواء حماسيه جدا بدون شك
والاستقطاب وصل الى اعلى مدى ممكن يمكن ان
تراقبي في اي لحظه في الشارع شخصين
يتحدثان
ويعارضان بعضهما البعض من حيث التوجه
السياسي متابعه اولا لما حصل بالامس او
لشؤون الحياه التركيه اليوميه التي يعني
يعانون منها فيما يتعلق بمواضيع الاقتصاد
واللاجئين او دعيني اقول تلك التي يختلفون
عليها الان يعني المعركه اصبحت اكثر حماوه
الناخب التركي اكثر اكثر حماسه بانتظار
بدا هذه الجوله الثانيه بعد اسبوعين هل
يعني تحدد التي ستحدد مصير تركيا ومصير
رجب طيب اردوغان في الرئاسه طبعا يعني
اليوم صحيح بعد هذه النتائج انه لا غالب
يعني ولا مغلوب ولكن بلغه الارقام
حقق استطاع الرئيس اردوغان ان يحقق نسبه
اعلى ولكنه لم يكن فوزا بين قوسين يعني
فوز الجوله الاولى
مريحا على الاطلاق
وكما كان يعد او يتوعد المعارضه ولا الطرف
الاخر ايضا استطاع ان يحقق ما كان يعد به
ويتواعد به الموالاه وهذا جعل البعض من
الطرفين يخيب امله رغم ملامح الفوز
واحتفالات الفوز التي كان يعني يخوضها
بالامس انصار اردوغان ورغم خطابه هو الذي
كان اشبه بخطاب الفوز كي لا نقول خطاب
كامل بطبيعه الحال ولكنه اشبه بخطاب الفوز
مقارنه بالتعهد بالاستمرار بالمضي قدما
وبشكل حاد وضرب باليد على
مكتبه اي اقصدار اوغلو بعد هذه الارقام
التي حققها اذا اسبوعان حاسمان فيهم
الكثير من الحماسه عند الناخب التركي
وربما من المفاجات التي قد تغير في مسار
اللعبه دعنا نذهب الى زميلنا زيدان لنعرف
منه ايضا الاجواء في انقره وخاصه انه
انقره اعطت اكثر الاصوات للمعارضه لكم
اولا زيدان لماذا هذه الاصوات بهذه
الكثافه كانت المعارضه في انقره وهي تعد
من العاصمه ومن ابرز المناطق والمدن في
تركيا
نعم ميسون تحيه لك ولطاهر ولجميع
المشاهدين لا شك ان المدن الرئيسيه انقره
او اسطنبول التي تقدم فيهما كمالك الجدار
اوغلو بنسبه طفيفه عن الرئيس التركي رجب
طيب اردوغان هي اكثر المدن التي تضررت من
التضخم وغلاء المعيشه وارتفاع الاسعار
لذلك الناخب هنا صوت وفق المنفعه
الاقتصاديه والضرر الاقتصادي الذي لحق به
وبالتالي اختار مرشح المعارضه بخلاف
الناخب التركي الذي في وسط الاناضول
ومناطق الزلزال وايضا في البحر الاسود
الذي بقي وصوت وفق قناعاته ومبادئه
والاديولوجيه التي
يعني يتمتع بها هذا الناقد وبالتالي صوت
للرئيس التركي رجب طيب اردوغان العامل
الاقتصادي لا شك كان حاضرا في انقره وفي
اسطنبول وربما موضوع الجيل زد او جيل
الشباب في هاتين المدينتين لكن في القرى
يعني في اسطنبول او حتى في انقره كان رجب
طيب اردوغان مرشح تحالف الشعب متقدما في
بعض المناطق لكن بالعموم محصله هاتين
الولايتين
ذهبت لكمال كلجدار اوغلو وهذا هو السبب
الرئيسي ميسون
بحسب كل المؤشرات في خساره الرئيس التركي
لاول مره في كل الانتخابات التي خاضها
يخسر اسطنبول وايضا العاصمه انقره تعطي
مرشح المعارضه
اصواتها ولو كان بنسبه لطيفه لكن هي هو
تقدم او تطور ملحوظ حقيقه في هذه
الانتخابات التي كانت حافله جدا بالمفاجات
سواء على صعيد الانتخابات الرئاسيه وظهور
اسم سنان اوغان
ظهر هذا الاسم من العدم وايضا الانتخابات
البرلمانيه وفوز تحالف الشعب بقياده رجب
طيب اردوغانبي الاغلبيه في البرلمان انهم
تراجعوا بشكل طفيف عن الانتخابات الماضي
لكن الاغلبيه البرلمانيه تعني كثيرا في
جوله الاعاده ميسون شكرا لك مراسل العربيه
زيدان كنت معي من انقره كما اشكر زميلنا
موف
ره
يعني حقيقه ايام طويله وساعات طويله وكبتم
فيها هذه الانتخابات ووضحت لنا اعطيتونا
صوره جدا واضحه عما كان يجري على الارض
شكرا لكما يعطيكم العافيه
اسبوعان امام رجب الطيب اردوغان ومنافسه
كمال كيليتشدار اوغلو باستماله الاصوات
وكسب المعركه في الجوله الثانيه
المعارضه برئاسه كيليتشدار اوغلو تركز في
سياستها على انهاء حقبه اردوغان
كيليتش دار اوغلو وحلفاؤه يريدون تغيير
النظام الرئاسي وتقليص صلاحيات الرئيس
اغلاق المشاريع الكبرى مثل قناه اسطنبول
وصندوق الثروه التركي
تحويل البلاد الى منطقه عازله وزياده عدد
مراكز اعاده اللاجئين واعاده السوريين
انهاء نظام ايداع الليره المحمي واعفاء
الشباب من رسوم جواز السفر وعود اردوغان
اردوغان يركز على سياسه دعم فئه الشباب
داخليا وقطاع التعليم وزياده اشراك المراه
في القوه العامله
وعود بتدابير جديده لمعالجه التضخم
وانهيار الليره التركيه
خارجيا يريد اردوغان اتباع سياسه الانفتاح
اكثر على الدول المنطقه والعالم
السباق بين المتنافسين في المرحله القادمه
يتطلب استقطاب اصوات نخيبي الخارجين من
الجوله الاولى
سنان اوغان ومحرم انجا قد يشكلان ورقه
الفوز في الجوله القادمه بالتحالف مع
احدهما
كشفت الانتخابات الرئاسيه التركيه عن فوز
اردوغان باحدى وخمسين مقاطعه مقابل 30
مقاطعه ذهبت لمرشح لمعارضه كمال في تفاصيل
ذلك خسر اردوغان اهم مقاطاعتين وهما
اسطنبول وانقره بعد انتصار اوغلو فيهما
بفارق ضئيل كذلك تمكن مرشح المعارضه من
السيطره على جميع المقاطعات في شرق تركيا
تقريبا وبعض الولايات في الجنوب الغربي
بينما سيطر اردوغان على مقاطعات الوسط
والشمال ابرزها واكبرها مقاطعه غونيا وكان
لافتا ايضا فوز كليتش دار اوغلو في بعض
الولايات التي تضررت بنكبه الزلزال مثل
هاتاي واضنه بينما فاز اردوغان في ولايات
اخرى متضرره كاشان لاورفا وغازي عنتاب
من اسطنبول ينضم الى الكاتب الصحفي
اوبتيال سيد يلمز اهلا بكم معنا اذا اردنا
ان نفهم هذه الخريطه خريطه الاصوات التي
اعطيت لكي الطرفين كيف يمكن فهمها والبعض
يتساءل لماذا اردوغان كانت اصواته اكبر في
الارياف بينما كانت الاصوات اكثر وكثيفه
اكثر في المدن
تحيه طيبه مساء الخير بالنسبه للمدن
الكبيره كما حصلت في الانتخابات
البلديات عام تسع تسعه عشر
هناك تقدم للمعارضه بشكل عام وصعود
للمعارضه ولذلك استطاع حزب الشعب الشعب
الجمهوري المعارض كسب بلديه اسطنبول
وانقره وازمر تقليديا انقره مع
حزب الشعب الجمهوري يعتبر معقل لهذا الحزب
اما بالنسبه
لانقره واسطنبول يعني خاصه الصعوبات
الاقتصاديه
ورف اجور
الايجار وما الى ذلك يعني صعوبه المشاكل
اليوميه والاقتصاديه التي تؤثر على
المواطنه اعتقد عامل مهم ولم يتغير لان
حزب حصل
فاز في هذين المدينتين الكبرتين كما سبق
في الانتخابات المحليه والامر مستمر وكذلك
يعني تقليديه
حزب الشعب الجمهوري
متقدم في مناطق الغرب
وخاصه في مناطق
الساحليه
من جنوب من انطاليا الى الغرب ازمير
ومنطقه ومنطقه راقيه بينما حزب العداله
والتنميه ذات
توجه محافظ
يتقدم في مناطق اكثر
مناطق محافظه مثل وسط انا طول الشمال
الاناضول يعني ما زالت انقره
لم يتغير الموضوع حزبه ولكن هذه الخريطه
ايضا التي تحدثنا عنها هل تشيء
بصوره معينه او سيناريو معين او مشهد معين
لنتائج انتخابات الاعاده
يعني بالنسبه للانتخابات الاعاده اولا انا
على راي ان مع تراجع بعض الاصوات في
اردوغان شخصيه ولحزبه ولتحالف اوروبا ولكن
ويعتبر فايز هذه الانتخابات لان لانه حصل
على الاغلبيه في البرلمان كحزب وكتحالف في
حاله تشكيل الحكومه سيستطيع اداره البلاد
بشكل مريح اما
والانتقال الى الجوله الثانيه
بفارق يعني ويحتاج فقط نصف الاصوات
لذلك يعتبر هو يعني اقوى حظا
لحس
الجو الثانيه هل هناك امل جدا استاذه
موضوع
الاصوات السنان اوغانا سنتابع ما قاله جون
كيرربي ايضا عن هذه الانتخابات ومن ثم
اعود اليك لنتحدث اكثر عن موضوع اصوات
سنان اوغان وكيف ستؤثر في جوله الاعاده
جونكورد بمشاهدينا قال طبعا وهو متحدث
باسم مجلس الامن القومي في البيت الابيض
قال ان امريكا تتابع عن كتب الانتخابات
التركيه مضيفا ان الرئيس الامريكي جو
بايدن يتطلع للعمل مع الفائز في
الانتخابات ايا كان من جهته الرئيس طيب
رجب طيب اردوغان قال في بيان له ان شعبه
انجز انتخابات الرئاسه التركيه والتي تعد
واحده من بين الاكثر مشاركه في تاريخ
تركيا مشيرا الى ان هذه الانتخابات تليق
بالديمقراطيه بلاده كما قال اردوغان انه
رغم تقدمه بمليونين ونصف المليون صوت فانه
ستكون هناك جوله اعاده للانتخابات مؤكدا
ان الاصوات التي حصل عليها
ستتضاعف وانه سيحقق فوزا تاريخيا في جوله
الاعاده
هذا ونشر كمالك مقطع فيديو على حسابه في
تويتر قائلا فيه انه سيقاتل حتى النهايه
على حد وصفه
[موسيقى]
كان ابوه قبطان بحريا لكنه عشق كره القدم
تمتع رجب طيب اردوغان بموهبه كرويه لافته
في الاعداديه والثانويه لعب لصالح نادي
جامع الرياضي مقابل الف ليره شهريا اطلق
عليه اصدقائه لقب الامام بيكنباور كابورا
ونمت مهاراته وتلقى عروضا من انديه اسكي
وفنر بهجه لكن والده عارض الامر
بدات في الرابعه عشر بلعب كره القدم في
الحي كنت وقتها طالبا في المرحله الثانويه
وكنت اتدرب في اكاديميه اسطنبول لكره
القدم ايضا بعد الانتهاء من المدرسه حاولت
دخول كليه التربيه الرياضيه واحتراف كره
القدم لكن والدي رحمه الله اعترض ومنعني
من اجل اكمال الدراسه ولم اتمكن من احتراف
كره القدم
منافسه في الانتخابات كمال كالجدار اوغلو
ولد بمنطقه ريفيه شرق الاناضول لعائله
علويه كان والده موظفا حكوميا فسار على
سير ابيه عمل محاسبا ثم تدرج في الوظائف
الحكوميه الى ان اصبح رئيسا لمؤسسه الضمان
الاجتماعي ساقت الاقدار الرجلين من عالم
الرياضه والوظيفه الى دهاليز السياسه حتى
المنافسه على رئاسه تركيا
[تصفيق]
ومع ذلك ما زال اردوغان لا يفوت فرصه الا
واظهر فيها مهاراته الرياضيه كذلك كليجدار
اوغلو الذي نشر صوره في المطبخ كموظف عادي
يساعد زوجته في الاعمال المنزليه
[موسيقى]
عود الى اسطنبول مع الكاتب الصحفيه
السيد يلمذ في جوله الاعاده من سيحسم هذه
النتيجه هل الاصوات سنان اوغان ستحسم
النتيجه
وماذا يمكن ان يقدمه الرئيس رجب طيب
اردوغان وايضا
من اجل جذب الاصوات من جديد خلال هذين
الاسبوعين
يعني من الظاهر جدا ان اردوغان هو الاقرب
الى الفوز في الجوله الثانيه لان لانه لا
يحتاج الا فقط
نصف من الصفر فاصله
خمسه يعني
نصف فقط
نصف درجه بينما السيد
يحتاج الى خمسه
نقط
وهناكير الاصوات الى كما
هل يضمن النجاح ام لا
اذا فرضنا ان جميع اصوات
سنان اوران ستذهب الى كردشتاروا وهذا ممكن
طبعا ولكن ممكن يعني افتراضيا ولكن واقعيا
يعني سنان اوغن ليس زعيم حزب واصواته جاءت
من من اشتات من مختلفه من اطراف المختلفه
من الشباب من اليسار الى اليمين ومن
القوميين وما الى ذلك
حتى اذا قررت لمن تتوقع ان يعطي الاصوات
لايردوغان ام لكم
هو يساوي مع الاثنين يبدو انه اقرب الى
اردوغان
واشترط الشروط تعجيزيه لكن اشتروا بمعنى
فك
التعاون مع حزب الشعوب الديمقراطيه وفي
حال
الابتعاد من هذا الحزب او من الاصوات
الكرديه يعني لا يبقى معنا بالنسبه
لكريشتار اودو
للحصول على اصواته
حقيقه يعني وهذا رقم كبير
نعم يعني البعض يعتبر يقول عشره وبعد اخر
يقول لعشرين على كل حال اشكرك من اسطنبول
يلمز على المشاركه معنا في اخبار الساعه
[موسيقى]
في اخبار الساعه سنتابع بعض لحظات قطاع
النفط في السودان يؤكد سيطره قوات الدعم
السريعه على مصفاه الخرطوم ويتهمها بتعطيل
التوزيع
[موسيقى]
نتابع اخبار الساعه مشاهدينا من ملف الحرب
في اوكرانيا حيث تعهد رئيس الوزراء
البريطانيه بتزويد كياف بمئات الطائرات من
دون طيار بعيده المدى ومجموعه متنوعه من
الصواريخ ليخرج هذالينسكي بمكاسب عديده من
جولته الاوروبيه خاصه في ظل خططه لتوسيع
الهجوم الاوكراني المضاد
حزمه عسكريه جديده ستسلمها لندن الى
القوات الاوكرانيه للدفاع عن اراضيها ضد
روسيا وطرد عناصرها من المناطق التي
احتلتها منذ بدء موسكو حمله العسكريه
العام الماضي رساله بريطانيه حملت طمانه
الشعب الاوكراني والرئيس الاوكراني الذي
حل ضيفا في زياره خاطفه لبيت ريسوسناك
الريفي من جهه وتحذيرا لموسكو من جهه اخرى
من المهم ان يعرف الكريم اننا سنستمر في
دعم اوكرانيا على المدى الطويل سنظل
صامدين في تقديم المساعده لاوكرانيا ليس
فقط الان لاستعاده اراضيها الشرعيه ولكن
ايضا لضمان ان اوكرانيا لديها وسيله
للدفاع عن نفسها
مئات صواريخ والانظمه الدفاعيه الجويه بما
فيها طائرات بدون طيار بعيده المدى
ستوفرها الحكومه البريطانيه لاوكرانيا
وتراها لندن ضروريه في مقاومه كياف حربا
فظيعه فرضتها موسكو على
الاوكرانيينسكي ممتن للدعم البريطاني
المتواصل لبلده حتى قبل بدايه الحمله
العسكريه لكنه يضغط للحصول على الطائرات
حربيه
تحدثنا اليوم عن تزويدنا بمقاتلات والامر
مهم جدا لاننا لا نتحكم في اجواءنا وهذا
معروف كوننا شركاء حقيقيين يعرف كل تفاصيل
ما يجري في ساحه المعركه ونريد انشاء
تحالف للحصول على الطائرات الحربيه وانا
متفائل جدا في هذا الخصوص لان هناك قرارات
مهمه ستتخذ قريبا
فيما المناقشات مستمره اكد سوناك ان بلاده
ستكون جزءا من تحالف دوليا لتقديم الدعم
الذي يطالب به زيلينسكي اجتماع الزعيمين
ياتي بعد ان وافقت الحكومه البريطانيه
الاسبوع الماضي على ارسال صواريخ بعيده
المدى لاول مره الى جانب الدعم العسكري
بقيمه مليارين وثلاثه مئه مليون جنيه
تعاهدت به لندن العام الماضي
لا توجد خطط لارسال طائرات حربيه بريطانيه
لاوكرانيا لكن وزاره الدفاع اكدت انها
ستدرب الطيارين اوكرانيين على طائرات اف
16 التي لا تستخدم في سلاح الجو الملكي
والحزمه العسكريه الجديده تاكيد على
مواصله وقوف بريطانيا مع الشعب الاوكراني
وحمايه اراضيه مصطفى زارو العربيه لندن
ينضم الى
الخارجيه الاوكراني اهلا بكم معنا هل هذه
الجوله الاوروبيه للسيد زلينسكي يمكن ان
نعتبرها ناجحه ام متعثره لانه لم يستطع
الحصول على مقاتلات
مساء الخير تحيه من كيف شكرا على
استضافتي اكيد ناجحه
بودره ان اشير بان هناك سلسله من زيارات
ناجحه قبل عشره ايام تقريبا رئيس اوكرانيا
خمس دول في شمال اوروبا فنلندا السويد
دينمارك
والان
اربع دول يعني رائده في في حلف اطلسي وفي
اتحاد اوروبي هاي مهم جدا لقد شخصيه بين
قاده اهم من كل شيء ولكن هذه العلاقات
الشخصيه يعني لا معنى لها اذا لم تتوج
بمصلحه اوكرانيا
في هذه الظروف ظروف الحرب مستمره منذ 15
شهر تقريبا
مش ممكن ان نتحدث عن كل شيء اكيد هناك
اتفاقيات ولكن غير مؤلمه قارى فقط الصحافه
بيننا سوف تاتي الى اوكرانيا الواردات
جديده من
انجلترا على سبيل المثال الصواريخ
جو ارض بعيده المدى 300 كيلو
والله
خطوه جديده
من اسلحه لاوكرانيا من قبل الغرب الى اي
حد ستستطيعون الاستفاده منه في هجومكم
المضاد
انا لا اريد ان اتحدث عن هجوم المضاد لان
هناك هجومات مستمره على طول يعني ولكن
يعني القياده الاوكرانيه سيد مكتينكو
دائما تتحدث وكل الزخم هو لهذا الهجوم
المضاد منذ اشهر وهي كانت بانتظار الربيع
لتقوم به يعني هذا الكلام ليس من عندنا من
عند القياده الاوكرانيه بانها مهتمه كثيرا
بهذا الهجوم
صحيح هذا الشيء مهم جدا
وصراحه جارنا الكبير والضخم يبدو لي يخاف
من هاي هجوم مش فقط كدوله بس الناس كمان
خايفين ليش
المعلومات الوارده هناك الاف والاف من
الناس
يهربون من مناطق المحتله الاوكرانيه
ويهربون من القرب هو هناك توابير سيارات
لمده ساعات وساعات على الجسر بين من قرم
شبه جزيره قرم المحتال وروسيا عند الجسر
سيد مكتينكو داني ان اذهب الان الى موضوع
كبير ايضا في كيف وهو موضوع الفساد الخاص
بهذه الاسلحه التي تصل الى اوكرانيا ومن
ثم اعود لمتابعه الحديث معك صمود اوكرانيا
في حرب هذا روسيا مشاهدينا لم يكن طبعا
لولا تدفق الاسلحه الغربيه كميات ضخمه من
الاسلحه ارسلت الى الجيش الاوكراني الذي
وقف ندا للند امام القوات الروسيه في اكثر
من جبهات لكن هل تستفيد اوكرانيا بشكل كلي
من الاسلحه الغربيه سؤال طرحته صحيفه
نيويورك من خلال تقرير يشير الى مخاوف من
ان نسبه من الاسلحه المقدمه الى اوكرانيا
تهرب الى السوق السوداء اذا اردنا ان ندخل
في التفاصيل تشير الصحيفه الى انكياف بصدد
خوض حرب اخرى موازيه لكنها داخليه هذه
المره في مواجهه الفساد فتهريب الاسلحه
يعد ظاهره منتشره في اوكرانيا حتى قبل
اندلاع الحرب مع روسيا ما جعل هذا الموضوع
يطفو الى السطح هو تداول تقارير عن بيع
صواريخ وطائرات الجافلين عبر الانترنت
قادمه من اوكرانيا كما ان مسؤولين
امريكيين اشاروا الى تسجيل حالات مشتبه
فيها لعمليه تهذيب اسلحه الاكثر من ذلك هو
تقديم مراقبي البانتاجون لحوالي 200 شكوى
تزعم رصد سوء استخدام الاسلحه في اوكرانيا
شبهه تهريب الاسلحه دفعت واشنطن الى اصدار
اوامر بتتبع ومراقبه الاسلحه المقدمه
لاوكرانيا لضمان استخدامها على النحو
المطلوب وتبقى مهمه مراقبه الاسلحه الصعبه
نوعا ما قياسا للكميه الكبيره التي تم
تسليمها لحد الان وهو ما اعترفت به
الكساندرا استينوفا رئيسه لجنه مراقبه
الاسلحه في البرلمان الاوكراني والتي قالت
انه من المستحيل لمراجعه مخزون الاسلحه
بشكل مستمر لكنها وفي الوقت نفسه نفت وجود
اي دليل على عمليات نقل اسلحه غير مشروعه
الجيش الاوكراني حقيقه يدرك جيدا خطوره
عمليه تهريب الاسلحه ليس فقط لانها تستنفذ
مخزوناته بل ايضا لانها قد تؤثر على تدفق
الاسلحه نفسها حيث ان واشنطن المحت الى
امكانيه تقليص امداداتها في حال ثبوت وجود
عمليات تهريب ضخمه وهو ما دفع بعض الجنود
الاوكران الى المخاطره بحياتهم للحفاظ على
الاسلحه من السوق السوداء تقول صحيفه
نيويورك تايمز كما تضيف ان بعض الجنود
اضطروا الى العوده لساحات المعركه والتاكد
من خلوها من اي اسلحه وذلك خشيه ان يحصل
عليها الجنود الروس او اي طرف اخر وهو ما
وضع كثيرين منهم في خطر حقيقي
مره جديده الكاذبه مع ضيفنا
يافيينكو مستشار وزير الخارجيه الاوكراني
سيد مكتينكو هل اوكرانيا تضمن للولايات
المتحده الامريكيه والغرب بان لا تصل هذه
الاسلحه
بهالاعداد الكبيره التي وصلتكم الى ايض
خطيره
انا مش بين مشاركين في
واردات الاسلحه
كدوله اوكرانيا هل تضمن ان
تذهب هذه الاسلحه الى الجيش الاوكراني
الذي يدافع عن ارضه ولا تذهب الى السوق
السوداء
اكيد
اسلحه هاي شي
مش بسيط
فاكيد هناك اتفاقيات واكيد هناك
بروتوكولات والى اخره وانا بعرف بينزا
تقريبا اكثر منذ من سنه على الاقل هناك
بعض من وفود من كونجرس الامريكي كان وفود
يزوروا اوكرانيا وكان حديث كان لقاءات
وكان بعض من خبراتون الى اوكرانيا لكي
يمارسوا يعني
يؤكد
استعمال الاسلحه داخل الاوكرانيه ووفق
للسحافه يمكن يهدس شيئا ما ولكن انا اتذكر
فقط شيء واحد لما
كانه كان
واحد يعني فنلندي في بحر بلتيكي ولكن انا
لست متاكد متاكد بين هذا مش صح كمان يعني
قوات اعلاميه من
الفساد في وزاره الدفاع الاوكرانيه وفي
صفوف الجيش بان هذه الاسلحه تستخدم للدفاع
عن الارض الاوكرانيه لايجاز انا شخصيا
متاكد بذلك فقط تستخدم للدفاع عن وطن عن
اوكرانيا واما فساد ففساد موجود في كل
مكان وحتى فساد في
الدفاع في وزاره الدفاع الاوكراني كانت
هناك اخبار بين
بعض من يعني اشياء حدثت فيما يتعلق
بماكولات المستورده والماكولات اللي تاتي
الى الجيش شكرا
باسعار مرتفعه شكرا
من كافه مستشار وزير الخارجيه الاوكراني
شكرا لك على المشاركه في اخبار الساعه
اتهمه مستشار الامن القومي في البيت
الابيض جون كربي ايران بتزويد روسيا
بطائرات مسيره هجوميه وانتحاريه منذ اغسطس
العام الماضي بلغت اكثر من 400 طائره في
اطار التعاون القائم بين مستوى وهران
واضاف كوربي ان واشنطن لا تزال ترى مؤشرات
على توسيع شراكه دفاعيه غير مسبوقه بين
روسيا وايران
[موسيقى]
الى الشان السوداني الان حيث طلب تجمع
العاملين في قطاع النفس السوداني كلا من
قوات الدفع السريع دعم السريع والجيش
السوداني بانهاء الحرف في بلاد وعدم تدمير
المنشات النفطيه واكد بيان التجمع ان قوات
الدعم السريع لا تزالوا تسيطر على مصفاه
الخرطوم ما خلق ازمات في التوزيع الامتداد
البلاد كما اضاف البيان ان مبنى رئاسه
شركه النيل الكبرى لعمليات البترول تعرض
ايضا لقذيفه ادت لاحداث خسائر بالغه
جددت الخارجيه الكويتيه دعوتها للاطراف
المعنيه في السودان بحمايه مقر البعثات
الدبلوماسيه بعد اقتحام وتخريب سكن رئيس
المكتب العسكري في سفارتها في الخرطوم
ومنذ بدء الحرب تكرر مسلسل الاعتداءات على
السفارات
وملحقات ثقافيه ودبلوماسيه نتابع
شهر على هذا الحال السودان يختنق فوضى لم
تفرق حرب لم تصدها حصانه ولا دبلوماسيه
تعدت اسوار السفارات والملحقات الثقافيه
الاردن المتضرر الاخير اعلن اقتحامه
وتخريب مقر سفارته في الخرطوم
اما في السادس من مايو حادثه اعتداء على
موكب تابع للسفاره التركيه لدى الخرطوم
قبل اقل من اسبوعين شهدت الملحقيه
الثقافيه السعوديه في السودان اقتحاما
واستيلاء على ممتلكاتها
وابل من الرصاص تعرضت له سياره مصفحه تتبع
للسفاره الامريكيه في الخرطوم
كما جرى الاعتداء على مقر اقامه سفير
الاتحاد الاوروبي في السودان
فيما تعرض مقر البعثه الدبلوماسيه
الفرنسيه للهجوم ادى الى تاجيل اجلال
رعايه فرنسيين
اطلاق الاعيره الناريه طال ايضا السفاره
الهنديه
حوادث الاعتداء على السفارات هذه عاده ما
كانت توربكو عمليات الاجلاء او تؤجلها غير
انها شاهده على خرق واضح لهدن لم تعرف
للصمود طريقا غذاء السالم العربيه
[موسيقى]
في اخبار الساعه سنتابع بعد قليل رئيسه
بيلاروسيا يظهر بعد ايام من غياب اثار
شائعات بشان حالته الصحيه
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد نتابع من تونس حيث قضت
محكمه مختصه في قضايا الارهاب بسجن راشد
الغنوشي رئيس حركه النهضه لمده عام
وتغريمه وذكرت المحكمه ان الغنوشي اودينا
غيابيا بوصف الاجهزه الامنيه بالطواغيت
الامر الذي يندرج ضمن افعال المجرمه وفقا
للقانون التونسي واعتبرته تحريضا على
استهداف قوه الامن
[موسيقى]
بعد اختفاء اثار الشكوك حول صحته ظهر رئيس
بيلاروسيه الكسندو في تصريحات حديثه له
امام مسؤولين عسكريين تطرق فيها الى اخر
الاحداث الميدانيه التي وقعت في مدينه
بيانسكا الروسيه على الحدود مع اوكرانيا
وروسيا في نفي غير مباشر للانباء
المتداوله حول صحته
بعد ثلاثه ايام من الاحداث التي وقعت
بالقرب منا اعني في منطقه بريانسك عندما
تم اسقاط اربع طائرات واضطررنا للرد نحن
في حاله تاهب قصوى لذلك انا مهتم بمعرفه
الوضع في جميع انحاء البلاد وبالطبع معرفه
وجهات النظر حول تطور هذا الوضع
غياب مثير للجدل بعد انتشار شائعات عن
تدهور صحه لوكاشينكو وتداول انباء عن
معاناته من مرض خطير دعت المعارضه
بيلاروسيه في المنفى الشعبي للاستعداد
للتغيير السياسي
بالنسبه لنا هذا يعني شيئا واحدا علينا ان
نتحضر جيدا لاي سيناريو من اجل تحويل
بيلاروسيا لطريق الديمقراطيه ومنع روسيا
من التدخل
[موسيقى]
هجمته اسماك القرش على البشر قد تكون امرا
معتادا ولكن تزاييدها وارتفاعها في مناطق
مختلفه من العالم يدفع الى التساؤل عن
الاسباب وما اذا كان لتغير المناخ دور في
ذلك
هذه لقطه لهجوم قرش على زورق كاياك قرابه
شواطئ هاواي وهذه الاريد فتاه امريكيه في
الثالثه عشر من عمرها تسببت لها سمكه قرش
بجراح غائره
اما هذا الشاطئ الهادئ فهو مسرح لعمليه
بحث تقوم بها الشرطه الاستراليه على جثه
راكب امواج هاجمته سمكه قرش ضخمه ما يجمع
بين هذه الهجمات رغم بعدها الجغرافي هو
تقارب تواريخها فكلها حدثت في الاسبوع
الثاني من شهر مايو 2023
هذه الوتيره المرتفعه لهجمات القرش فسرها
بعض العلماء بكونها مرتبطه بتاثيرات
المناخ التي تدفع باسماك القرش للاقتراب
من الشواطئ نظرا لتناقص كميات ما تقتات
عليه هذه الاسماك مما يدفعها الى البحث عن
مصادر مختلفه للطعام من جهه اخرى يقول
عالم الاحياء البحريه البريطاني ديفيد
جاكوبي ان تصرفات البشر هي سبب ارتفاع
هجمات القرش حيث ان الصيد الجائر واقتراب
مرتدي الشواطئ من المياه متوسطه العمق
والعميقه سباحه وعبر الزوارق الصغيره تكون
مستفزه لهذه الاسماك التي توصف بكونها
عنيفه ولكنها في الواقع هي التي تتعرض
لهجوم بشري ان اسم ماسي العربيه
اردوغان يعد
بثور خيه وكاله تعهد بقتالا حتى النهايه
اما سنن اوجان يضع شروطه
جوله زيليسك الاوروبيه تملا مخازن
اوكرانيا بالصواريخ والمسيرات لكنها تتعثر
فيما يتعلق بالمقاتلات
واشنطن تتهم طهران بتقديم 400 مسيره
انتحاريه لموسكو منذ اغسطس وتقول ان
شاركتهما تتوسع
محكمه تونسيه مختصه بقضايا الارهاب تقضي
بالسجن عاما للراشد الغنوشي زعيمي حركه
النهضه
اشكر لكم طيب المتابعه اترككم في امان
الله
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات